Jaakko have had discipline equals
freedom audio on repeat since its
release and I love it question if our
greatest strength is our greatest
weakness then how is discipline which is
obviously your strength your greatest
weakness first of all I don't even know
what I don't know if discipline would be
my greatest strength I don't know I mean
I'm a disciplined person yeah no doubt
but I think I think that I think that
one of the things that people would find
interesting is that I'm not overly
orderly mmm-hmm so if you think about
those like psychological characteristics
one of them is extreme orderliness which
normally goes hand-in-hand with highly
disciplined people you know those people
that are there just ultra highly
disciplined but they have to have
everything they're they're OCD they're
OCD orderly right and I I'm not like
them about a lot of things I am about
some things but like it's pretty funny
actually
my floor in my garage mm-hmm when I
workout isn't is not clean right it's
got salt stains on it from sweat yeah
and it's dirty right and occasionally
I'll get someone saying you should clean
that floor or a man you should clean
that pool man that's nasty but it's
totally functional right yeah and my
point is that I I don't I don't freak
out about it it's functional it doesn't
bother me at all that it's not perfectly
orderly this also means that I don't
mind when things don't go as planned
right so a lot of times you get people
that are a high end of disciplined yeah
they're - they're too far they're not
balanced so now when things don't go the
way that they've planned things to go
they start to lose it a little bit they
can't deal with it they want they want
to have everything in order all the time
and I'll tell you that's not the way
life works that's certainly not the way
combat works but that's not the way life
works
and I don't really mind that I don't
mind chaos so I would say probably if if
you look at discipline as a strength I
don't think I think that would be
generally considered the weaknesses of
being hyper disciplined is that you you
can't stand when things are not in order
yeah you can't stand like I missed a
workout this is you know you freak out
completely like you know okay I don't
like missing a workout I don't lose my
mind go for it yeah now all that being
said I would say that I am a very much a
creature of habit and I do like to do
the same things over and over again I
don't like to travel even though I have
to travel a little time on Elektra I'd
rather stay home I pretty much eat the
same food all the time and go to the
same three or four restaurants all the
time Yeah right
I like to follow routine as much as I
can you know it's even in jiu-jitsu I do
the same basic movements all the time I
have the same you know I've talked about
like a funnel-like
everywhere that you go with me it's
gonna lead to where I want you to be
because I'm gonna use those same moves I
surf the same spots all the time so I
guess I guess for me the way that
discipline is weakness or whatever for
me is that it may I think I'm I could be
fairly boring and predictable yeah for
other people yeah yeah like you know
yeah hey you want to go try this thing
at my home no not really
yeah don't really want to I think you're
right about that though yeah cuz I'm the
same thing even are you same way exact
same ways wrong like I I I'm not highly
disciplined echo charm well I'm not
highly this one I mean but like the same
stuff like over and over again the was
funny I could I don't even like new
movies okay you seem like oh you know
what well I I haven't had time to watch
movies for a long time yeah but but when
I used to watch movies to be okay I'm
gonna watch The Big Lebowski again yeah
yeah well I have that kind to the
but Big Lebowski that can't move either
okay so movies are different I'm not
going a whole thing about this but this
there's two types of different two types
of movies in this situation there's
movies that are like awesome and good
storyline maybe a great reveal at the
end or twist or whatever and it's like
good good story and then there's like
the type of movie that's just a series
of good parts where the story doesn't
really matter that much sometimes good
some of the junk but it's less about
that it's more about this like the good
parts it's like oh there's part in this
but that's how the Big Lebowski is like
it's just a series of really good parts
yeah
and it's awesome yeah yeah that's what I
mean I think they're both awesome but
the one with that have what was the
other one just the storylines awesome
okay
you know like um I can't think of
anything I thought my head but Big
Lebowski is one of those look like
Napoleon Dynamite yeah yeah like that's
another one it's just a bunch of good
parts who cares about what happens a
thing in fact you probably forget really
I mean you remember what happens at the
end for the storyline you don't really
care but you'll watch it over and over
because all the parts are funny or good
or whatever and like Point Break for
example I know we talked about the first
yeah yeah that's a good that's a series
of great parts like this
I'm surfing more the sky David part the
behemoth at all the part they're just
really fun I mean sure the story is good
it's who it's fine
we'll say that but that's not the point
the point is like you know anyway Jack
back to the point though is oh when
we're talking about like being
repetitive like liking the same yeah
boring being boring I'm boring yeah cuz
I okay so I'm like that right where I
eat a lot of sushi all the time and
there's a sushi restaurant within
walking distance of my house like it's
blackboard line drive but I go there
like not as much as I'll probably go
like maybe three times a week now but
there is a point where I was going five
to six pieces week for every time more
than one so of course they just love ask
me and my brother goes to so yeah they
just love me in there cuz like okay
again again or just pretty no probably
responsible for a significant portion of
their revenue my wife she's not like
that
oh she likes a different answer saying
yeah it's like variety in whatever and
so my wife will say you know let's say
we're gonna go out for dinner
yeah that's try something different yeah
I said okay tell me where yeah yes well
we just go to
hey things yeah yeah say at least you
have a few like difference right yeah
I've I - and they're both sushi places
mmm so it's like and it goes for like
what we do to during the weekend it's
like really repetitive yeah my wife uses
the word Groundhog Day planning like a
lot
- speaking of great movies another one
great parts a bunch of great parts but
really who cares at the end you know
like this story what's that what's that
movie really about that what's the story
about that movie you don't know yeah I
totally know I've seen it look like what
you got to be nice to the girl so the
ground all day stops like I don't know
what them yeah yeah it doesn't makes it
like good but it's a good movie anyway
so that was the point of the movie thing
but but yeah so there the point is with
this is that yeah you will be boring
because my wife thinks I'm born in that
way what it's like it's just the same
old same old
every single time I'm like Brian love
this all-inclusive finger whatever they
may be this is like way better you know
and yeah so yeah I think you're right I
think that money but so if you think
discipline isn't your biggest strength
what is what do you think your biggest
strength is oh I don't know I don't
think I have any big stress you know
what I think it is I think it it's
arguable maybe discipline yeah maybe
maybe not but Mallett essentially
balance yeah you're imbalanced know
you're pretty balanced yep you know I
think it is wrong you told it to me - oh
you're durable Oh in terms of physical I
think even mental - though that's the
thing like you're you're like a durable
part you know how like people like
you've told me stories of I'm going to
them but you told me stories about
someone who made like huge mistakes you
know with you and you'd like handle it
and it doesn't seem like it like bothers
you hmm you know like that can stuff
stuff that like ya know I do well and
you know it to me I guess that's that's
balance to me yeah but to me balances I
don't I don't
it's it's it's also boring alright
because I don't go far in one direction
the other direction I don't get extreme
about this or extreme about that I just
I I think that's what has
been good for me yeah was I never
freaked out about stuff much yeah yeah
that makes sense